exterior partnered building Wayne rolls
the ice bag up the steps of the
apartment complex shown earlier needy
follows him cradling her wrist she
motions for him to use the keys around
the neck he refuses Wayne come on Wayne
he shakes his head boy you need help
using a key around the neck a
left-handed need he gets the door open
with her right hand on the third try
Wayne rolls the ice bag in need he gazes
up at the cold blue sky interior hallway
moments later needy and Wayne here loud
moans through the closed front door
perplexed she motions for him to unlock
it he refuses she shoves him aside and
puts her key into 3lakhs interior
apartment continuous needy and Wayne
enter to find the couch occupied by a
half-naked couple the bulky man on top
is daddy 34 who goes by Frankie the
tired woman is mom mom her best feature
is her weave sparse furnishings the
couch small TV stereo and coffee table
are from a three are all from thrift
store the room reeks of reefer get off
my momma
Wayne lunges forward ready to fight
needy holds him back with her right hand
she smiles wildly at daddy as if an
illusionist had concerned him up during
a magic show it's daddy Wayne I know who
it is
daddy pulls up his jeans it is the fruit
of my loom so crazy whoa sorry y'all I
guess we got a little carried away just
catching up boo daddy hiding her left
hand need he goes over to hug her daddy
and starts coughing Wayne stays put
clutching the bag of ice beam
you never could handle a little smoke
grab me another beer interior kitchen
continued shelves are stocked with
enough canned goods for use after a
national disaster need he grabs a beer
with a six-pack on the dingy table she
spots a small paper bag with her name on
it roaches on the bag scamper away when
she touches it back in the living room
one arming the beer in bag Nitti sets it
sets them on the table happy birthday
Nitti
daddy an upside of course he did just
cuz he's been away little while three
years a little wild doesn't mean he got
memory loss he's not from that joint
maybe from this one though go on open an
excited needy opens the bag with her
right hand it's a balk of a box of Lee's
fortune cookies
she is visibly disappointed instant
Chinese cookies we always pass by into
stores she's loved them back in the day
that's right baby anytime we be eating
them she'd be crying for me to read her
what my say my mum pulls the box from
need his hands yeah now let me open
these for you
mm I ain't her to thank you yet thank
you my money excitedly opens a cookie
and Han wants to Daddy
mine say you were gonna have some new
clothes what kind of Fortune is that
what y'all say Frankie I forgot how
nasty these things taste here daddy
hands mama I'm his fortune y'all say you
make change for the better
yes I know that's right my mom breaks
open another cookie eats half reads the
fortune then places it on the table ma
mom you get me anything
hey I've got your daddy for you what
better president there than that my mom
hugs daddy then stares sternly at Wayne
Wayne Wayne does not flinch he grips the
bag of ice even tighter
Wayne Wayne's head turns towards mom mom
get over here right now greet your daddy
Wayne drops the ice shuffles over and
awkwardly hugs daddy little man I teach
you to ease up you don't even know come
on daddy smokes the joint then motions
for Wayne to follow suit Wayne looks at
it wide-eyed then runs back to needy hi
my little man mama laughs then
obsessively breaks oh brother cookie
reads the fortune and places it on the
table why do you got a bag of ice anyway
needy hurt herself
Wayne realizes his missed up only after
speaking needed rolls her eyes upset by
her brother's incessant dimness again my
mom reaches for her toolbox and pulls
out a tape measure how many times I got
a whoop you need it before you learn to
stop after the mess
mom extends the tape measure and needy
backs away chill marker it's a birthday
we'll put the model